[Music]
so comes from Pakistan yeah of course
Emma's mates are coming and I know one
who would be perfect for you she's not
fussy really out of the top and stay
there I want to be a writer but my
family is stuck in another century
writing isn't a job I need you to do
more makeup ich bitte
kiss the girl and get out of this dump
Bruce the direct line to all destroying
this shitty world seriously what does he
know about our worlds
[Music]
you should be listening to our music
before you start getting confused and
hating yourself
[Music]
I listen to everything I can feel it all
right here it's like Brewster does
everything ever felt everything I've
ever wanted
[Music]
four poems they're not brilliant put
their minds you think that this man
sings for people like us but he talks to
me
[Applause]
[Music]
you cannot be serious my dream was to
come here and work hard for my family if
you don't try to fix this we will lose
our son for good
this guy is incredible you've never
heard lyrics like is that Billy Joel
Billy Joel you try and raise your kids
right
[Music]
Boosh things about not letting the
hardness of the world stop you from
there in the best of you slip away my
hope is to build a bridge to my
ambitions but not a wall between my
family and me hopeful to your visit
I'm going to sing Bruce Springsteen's
hometown I can't think of a better
reason to visit the United States and to
see the home with the boss traps like us
baby we were born to run did you write
that I've told you before your lyrics
are rubbish I didn't even rhyme
[Music]